we're gonna begin with this a massive
search now underway in Northern
California for a long time automotive
writer who mysteriously disappeared
while on a motorcycle trip near the
Sierra Nevada some of Davey Johnson's
belongings have been recovered but
police have no idea where he is
CTM national correspondent Rica Duncan
is following the storied Rica what do we
know about this disappearance good
morning Tony well for starters police
found Davey Johnson's motorcycles
Saturday his girlfriend says he had been
on the road test driving it for an
assignment when he went missing
Wednesday now a team of 45 people six
dogs two boats in a helicopter have been
deployed to try and find him he is so
full of life and I have just never met
anyone like him
Jacqueline Schwab says her boyfriend
Davey Johnson is known for being
adventurous but it's completely out of
character for him to disappear for this
long there are just so many questions
that we have Trop said she last spoke to
Johnson around 5:00 Wednesday morning
the 44 year old had been testing out a
motorcycle four-story drop says he did
not text her for several hours according
to her he said his cell phone died and
he had been dealing with difficult
riding conditions I'm so sorry I worried
you he texted yes I'm okay and alive but
I'm wiped
I love you very much I don't think he
had a planned route Trop says she and
investigators are now trying to piece
together johnson's route Trout believes
on Sunday June 2nd Johnson wrote from
Los Angeles to Las Vegas the next day he
went from Las Vegas to Mammoth Mountain
in California and from there on Tuesday
he headed to the Sonora Pass the Sonora
Pass is the second tallest highway pass
in the Sierra Nevada known for its
winding steep and sometimes icy roads
even in June trop says despite poor
conditions she believes Johnson made it
over the pass by early Wednesday which
was the last time anyone heard from him
he texted a friend of his to say that he
was sitting in the creek at the rest
stop just enjoying himself
police found Johnson's bike Saturday
parked at a rest stop in Calaveras
County California Trapp says the next
day his clothing cellphone and laptop
by a river about 50 feet away his wallet
is still missing drop isn't giving up
hope but says as each day passes it gets
harder we always talked about having the
forty years together and we had a forty
year timeline and to have that cut short
is horrible Johnson is a respected
contributor to the car and Driver
magazine a spokesperson said in a
statement the entire team is eagerly
awaiting positive news about his rescue
drop told us she and Johnson had only
been dating a few months but that they
plan to get engaged in the coming weeks
so very pleased have any speculation
whatsoever they just you know not right
now in terms of what they're telling us
just the things that they found they put
out alerts asking for people to call
them if they have any information so
we're waiting I mean this goes back last
Wednesday yeah yeah
we hope they find them Jericka thank you